good morning Hank it's Tuesday so one
thing people might not know is that over
100 people work full time with us
between our educational Media company
complexly and our e-commerce company
dftba.com and these people range from
20-somethings to grandparents from
Warehouse managers to customer service
representatives to sound designers so
until recently all these people were
ultimately led by CEO Hank Green but
then Hank you got fired by cancer one
day cancer called in was like Hey for
the next several months you're not going
to do anything but undergo rigorous and
grueling treatments to deal with me and
you were like okay but I'm still gonna
make ads for the awesome socks club and
for the Crash Course coin and sometimes
I'm going to want to shoot scishow just
because like that's the mood I'm in and
I'm going to Tweet 72 times per hour and
call my brother Daley to pitch new
business ideas and make astonishingly
brilliant vlogbrothers videos even when
I don't feel well and write long and
beautiful emails to my brother about why
I believe that humanity is basically
worth it all while experiencing a bunch
of Novel and extremely unpleasant
varieties of pain so anyway you got
fired and then as a result I kind of got
hired as the CEO a prospect that nobody
was excited about you know like
historically I'm not great at meetings
usually when I attend a meeting I'll
just kind of stare at my socks which are
awesome by the way and then eventually I
might say something like you know if 10
people attend a 30 minute meeting it's
actually a 300 minute meeting which
makes me think about how human life and
detention are overwhelmingly the most
valuable resources in the history of our
planet and that's like 300 minutes of
human soul life just
gone and that it turns out is like not
the vibe for most meetings also I can't
really read a spreadsheet which
significantly limits my business
capacity and I wouldn't say I'm like
renowned for my leadership skills like
there's a reason that most of my career
has been spent here in the basement
alone typing also and this turns out to
be critically important I wasn't
familiar with any of the tlas the
three-letter acronyms of business like
CAC which is customer acquisition cost
or LTV or Roi or Roe which turns out to
be something different than Roi and yet
Hank I kind of love being the part-time
temporary reluctant marginally competent
CEO of these two extraordinary companies
like I would say this regardless Hank
because I don't want to make you feel
bad while you're going through cancer
treatment but I I genuinely don't resent
having this opportunity to be
unexpectedly promoted for a brief period
of time now I will be very happy to hand
the reins back to you and eventually to
other C EOS who can lead these companies
better than I ever could but I love this
like I really love the people we work
with and I love the stuff they make I
love eons I love Journey to the micro
Cosmos I love crash course and scishow
these are all things I watch every day
on YouTube but now as a result of this
promotion I actually understand a little
bit about how they happen and I love the
stuff we make at dftba Nathan Zeds good
enough hoodies and aerial besettes I'm
thinking about books shirt and Tyler
Thrasher's cicada plushie and Kurtz
gazat's timeline of complex life this
stuff is awesome and not to sound like a
CEO but I am so grateful to the team at
dftba who on a recent visit taught me
how the warehouse works and how to pack
up awesome coffee for subscribers right
that reminds me the awesome coffee Club
is accepting new members right now it's
the best coffee in the world but also
the awesome socks Club is open right now
which only happens like twice a year
it's open for a week
game changing socks and I think we all
know I can't sell socks like Hank can
but oh my God they're so comfortable you
don't even feel the toe seam style
impeccable fit incredible Mission
charitable but the biggest reason I've
been able to embrace and enjoy this job
despite its many meetings is that I love
our wise every company has a y right a
problem they're trying to solve a hole
in the marketplace they're trying to
fill and our wise are in my opinion
anyway the best we're trying to connect
creators to fans we're trying to lower
barriers to education and we're trying
to expand access to health care and
having those great whys makes me feel
fired up it understands why I have to go
to meetings it makes that human shared
time not feel wasted but well used we
are working albeit in small and
insufficient ways on the Injustice that
college costs in the United States are
so high and on the Injustice that Global
maternal mortality rates are so high so
yeah I'm not gonna say like thank you
for the job Hank because you don't want
me to have it and I also don't want to
have it but I am really grateful to you
and the people you work with for
building such extraordinary companies
that have such wonderful whys and my
biggest conclusion from this whole
Affair so far Hank is that being the
tale to your comet is the world's best
job so thank you and Hank I happen to
know that you pre-made a vlogbrothers
video because you knew that you were
going to be too sick this week to make
one which is unnecessary but I also know
that no matter how many times I and all
of nerdfighteria tell you that you don't
have to make a video every week you
respond by saying stop telling me that I
can't do what I love doing and want to
do so thank you for doing what you love
doing and want to do and I will see you
on Friday